i have i have big plans that's why i
invested in having a dead person in my
leg because
so just for the listeners if you're not
watching this
uh he has a brace on his leg because mcl
acl pcl
um i have no pc i haven't had that for a
long time and i have it at mcl
and the acl is really stretched out and
some meniscus damage so
i got a new mcl across there to hold the
whole thing in place and then he
tightened up
my meniscus and cleaned up some stuff in
there and seems to think that i'm gonna
get a lot more stability than i've had
since mayhem snapped it off but many
years ago mayhem gave you a kick right
that [ __ ] yeah it was right after i had
the trophy and forrest griffin kicked me
in one leg
when he had the sasquatch like he was
dressed as a sasquatch yeah but he
kicked me being funny and i turned
around went ahaha
and it was funny because it was on the
thigh and then mayhem came to the other
side
and kicked me right on the kneecap on
the side of it and it snapped my knee
out
did you know right away no it it popped
out like so he did
the whole crowd saw it everyone was like
no he did not just break that dude's leg
after he won now is it fair to say your
knees are probably
shot because of all your years of
skateboarding yeah yeah they're already
i've already torn my acl twice in this
one once on that one
like i said no pcl's for the longest
time i feel like [ __ ] forget how good
of a skateboarder you were
i always said when we brought you up on
the show last week i'm like
dude you're talking about with top three
in the world at one point
you know i ate yesterday on the
boardwalk and a guy came up to me and
said no way jason alex you know the mask
on and [ __ ] and i was like oh wow cool
he's like missed it's on an honor to me
and one time i met you at a trade show
like 15 years ago and i was like cool
man well nice to meet you
and then the guy the security guy goes
who's that he's like you know who that
is
it's jason ellis made his legendary
skateboarder and i just looked at my
wife and went
yeah yeah hell yeah you know i don't
care
that's like those are like every 10
years you get one of those i'm like
yes random dude legendary legendary
random guy
face mascot yeah i think they forget
because you're shut
such a personality now and on serious on
all over and doing
you know ls mania and stuff like that
they forget that you're a
high the highest level skateboarder so
do i i mean when you're saying it i'm
like
oh yeah yeah no a little bit that's all
really that's the other bit to finish
the knee off trying to
get back into it because i've been
trying to i made a decision that i
wanted to
ride again love that and then when i got
on the rail went to tony's and uh
skated for a week tony hawk yeah every
time i knee slid i could tell
that it was standard yeah johnny danza
don't throw out the name tony
and then i was at tony's sorry i've been
hanging out with skateboarders too much
again yes
yeah so anyway birdman so we got so
loose that
i knew that i had to do this to skate
again and then how's the uh
how serious going all that i think it's
going good
that's the thing people don't jase and i
are buddies yeah
it's where we talk no because you're
busy i'm busy it's where we talk
and you're just doing the goddamn thing
on seriously i would talk to you i have
time for you
yeah i have time for you dude we'll see
there's like there's only like three or
four people
actively doing it that i look at and i
go
they're they're the creme de la creme
and he's he's as good as anybody
as far as radio broadcasting he's been
doing for a hot second
yeah he's up and downs with it although
it's and it's not all
like it's a lot harder than
skateboarding even though you don't get
hurt but i feel like just the up and
downs of
like you have a lot more freedom you're
you you're your boss i have people that
you know would be really good jason i've
always had that since the show started
and i'm like well probably what i'm
doing because it seems to be working
they're like no no no
this would be and i'm like that's not
nope that's not true and then working
with people that you're not you're not
butt buddies they put you together and
you start to
like myself and the people i work with
couldn't be more opposite
like what are we into what do we do were
those complete opposites how
those people are brought on from serious
like you didn't get a picture total
accident it's me being an accident
because they're like well tony hawk's
friends
kind of funny like make him a dj and
they're like wow the show's getting big
we need to get him some help and there
was more like uh as far as the other
guys knew they were like hey can you
help this guy do a show for a day
and then they stayed and now 15 years
later we've
most of us have been working together
for over 10 years couldn't be more
opposite but
couldn't be more perfect yeah it could
be a good and bad thing
like kevin kraft kevin kraft's like like
a comic book nerd who's into like cinema
and like he's like the comic-con guy
he's
he's that dude and tully's like this
oxford educated really like erudite
intellectual
and it's such an amazing balance to
jason who's like that's
not him you know i had i had breakfast
with tully on
this weekend and my wife said the same
thing she's like that's like
that's the perfect guy to be sitting
next to jason because he's just so
well informed on so many things because
if you picked it it might be [ __ ]
you know it might be could it be another
friend it'd be dingo it'd just be too
australian saying [ __ ] oh my
[ __ ] [ __ ] mate what's the news i
don't [ __ ] know what's new
dingo i don't mind it though he's fine
well
that's that's an angle like i feel like
i feel like you have
enough ability and you believe in
yourself you could probably do it
by yourself really so if i want to
because that's the other thing people
forget
i did do it by myself that's how it got
big enough for other people to be there
so i can do that it just makes it easier
to me it's like uh i like relying on
myself howard stern has all these people
and
really at the bottom line probably for
our show he probably does 30 minutes of
him
his content to me like i like the
pandemic i like that there's nobody
around
i like i don't have an executive
producer what are we going to do today
i don't want to know like i used to like
it when it was like what are you going
to do and i smoke a giant and
[ __ ] throw out [ __ ] and it would work
that's what i love so when it's
when it's like oh we're going to do this
and we've got this guest and we're going
to do this tighten up
yeah tighten up yeah that's like the
pressure is so much more when it's
all these things have to play out i like
it better when it's
but that's tully and kevin like
structure they
and and you've got to work you can't
that's the thing i've learned in the
years of doing the jason
show is you don't barge on everybody all
the time like i think i
came in with a little bit of i just kind
of mcgregored the [ __ ] out of this radio
show when i first started i'm like i'm
just get over it
i'm the best there ever is so whatever
your opinion is if
if you're not spot on with it i'll
probably nail you to the wall for it be
like what the [ __ ] i'm not picking apart
you don't even know anything why would i
even listen to you if you're gonna say
such stupid [ __ ] but i i think you need
that arrogance or cockiness to make it
at first
i was the exact same way okay exact same
i always said it's like you've made
adjustments
oh dude dear god have i ever i mean i
haven't struggled now with it with
the team here in in my text me and
shouldn't have to have a conversation
today because
through chat might i don't for whatever
and it's a problem you're going to say
the same thing
it's a problem across the board when i
text it's
brutal yeah and chin's like dude like i
send this text he's like dude what the
[ __ ] this isn't you man
he said call me because the texts are
brutal and it suffers in my personal
life
business life yeah i'm like my i read an
email that i sent to
a big advertiser like dude what the [ __ ]
who are you talking to i'm like you wow
it's but it's through email because i've
done the same and then when they call
like you're a different person i'm like
it's just the way i tax it's aggressive
well and it's hard with those two
because they're so hard to get along
with i mean they're really
absolutely
brother my girl my family member every
my techs are aggressive
i looked at him like all right in the
beginning that that
that um me against the world kind of
uh take no prisoners attitude it it's
really effective
but i always say it's like um it's like
jelly beans compared to like a sweet
potato
the jelly beans give you amazing energy
and they get you fired
up time for 20 minutes and then you
realize like that it's not sustainable i
don't know if that's weird
you know you're like learning how to i
don't know if it ever goes well i always
have it it's just controlling the
monster
like at the chip on my shoulders i
couldn't tell you how tall it is
every day this morning that you know i i
woke up and you know i have a nice house
and
great family i drove my dream car here
but that chip's still like [ __ ] this
it's just
it's gonna make it more difficult for
sure get a couple of losses under your
belt
get a couple people that are a little
bit like on your level to like spank you
back where you belong
i get all that'll help you yeah my
friends are all smarter and more
successful are they
i don't have any friend who's not more
successful than me maybe that's my that
hurts
because you're essentially saying we're
not friends
really that's right you guys are better
off than you're better off than i i've
always known
i'm stupid so you're not hurting my
feelings i have no education i'm on fire
for a dumb guy
like i'm your cr i don't have my dream
car but i have a dream car for a dumb
guy you're not
you're not you're not dumb and drew and
i'm talking you know you're not
you don't you're not educated you're not
educated but your brain
is your brain functioning i did very
well i admit that it's different i just
it's
different bashing myself trust me when i
say dumb guy i know the [ __ ] smartest
guy in the room or i'm just trying to
[ __ ] be flattering to you
[Applause]
when i get off stage with the laugh
actually right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this from a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son